hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay the social responsibility
of business is to increase its profits
milton friedman argues that the entire
discourse about social responsibility
is problematic and ultimately bad he's
going to say that it attacks the very
foundations of a free society and
before that he says a few other things
he tells us that it's a rather vague
concept that isn't well understood it
lacks analytic rigor he also tells us
that it amounts to imposing taxes on
employers customers and employees and
there's all sorts of reasons why that's
a fundamental problem but then he tells
us and he uses a very interesting
metaphor here that it provides a cloak
for actions that would be justified on
other grounds friedman doesn't say
that one should never be for example
charitable or help anybody out he just
thinks that that's not supposed to be a
function of business so what does he
mean by saying that it provides a cloak
for actions it's providing a kind of
disguise
and we should call things what they
actually are
and he tells us we could conceive of
instances where a corporation might in
fact do something that say good for
a community or contribute to a charity
so he gives you an example here he says
it may be in the long run interest of a
corporation that is a major employer in
a small community to devote resources to
providing amenities to that community or
to improving its government so you know
sponsoring the the little league team or
the 4-h thing or creating scholarships
or
uh you know creating initiatives to
beautify the park or clean up the
riverbed or improve as he says the
governmental offices to try to make
government fair more equitable all of
those things could be good
for that company why he says they may
make it easier to attract desirable
employees it may reduce the wage bill
less in losses from pilferage and
sabotage or have other worthwhile
effects it could be good to help pay for
for example part of a road so that you
can get your products out to the
marketplace more easily that all makes
sense friedman is saying
another example of this and this depends
quite a bit on how
taxes are are structured right he says
it may be given the laws about the
deductibility of corporate charitable
contributions the stockholders can
contribute more to charities they favor
by having the corporation make the gift
rather than doing it themselves since
they can in that way contribute an
amount that otherwise would have been
paid as corporate taxes so maybe it
makes sense if you you know have a large
corporation and the stockholders want to
see malaria wiped out in africa maybe
the corporation sponsors that or you
know
water for for people lacking water
inoculations whatever it happens to be
right
those are in the company's long-term
interests those are in the stockholders
long-term interest it makes sense to do
that so then friedman says
why then
call it
social responsibility
why not just call it what it is a
rational long-term strategy
which is supposed to provide the
benefits that you want to
provide or produce
he says
there are many many cases like this
where there's a strong temptation to
rationalize that is to explain
these actions as an exercise of social
responsibility
and he goes on to say
in the present climate of opinion with
its widespread aversion to capitalism
profits the solas corporation and so on
this is one way for a corporation to
generate goodwill as a byproduct of
expenditures and friedman sees this as
essentially duplicitous
you know why
hide what you're doing why pretend that
you're doing it out of just the goodness
of your heart and not admit that you're
doing it because it works out well for
you by doing so
and and friedman also admits he says
that i don't really have grounds for
criticizing this i i it says it would be
inconsistent of me to call on corporate
executives to refrain from this
hypocritical window dressing because it
harms the foundation of a free society
because that would be to call on them to
exercise a social responsibility towards
that free society so friedman himself is
attempting to be completely consistent
in this
but then he goes on and he says
you know though it actually does attack
the foundations of a free society to do
this to to adopt this sort of mindset
why would that be bad for a free society
he talks about the schizophrenic
character of many business people he
says that
the use of the cloak of social
responsibility and the nonsense spoken
in its name by influential and
prestigious businessmen this is
problematic he says
business people are capable of being
farsighted and clear-headed in matters
that are internal to their business so
in their field they're experts they
they're objective they do what they want
to do
but outside their business they're
incredibly short-sighted and
muddle-headed
in things that are outside but do affect
the possible survival of their business
in general
and so he says we see businesses calling
for all sorts of things wage and price
guidelines or controls or income
policies
and he says that this short-sightedness
is exemplified in speeches by business
people on social responsibility and what
it ends up doing is strengthening a
mindset that says that pursuit of
profits is wicked immoral and must be
curbed and controlled by external forces
so what are they doing they're really
setting up
a
coming
of government bureaucracy because who
who are going to be these external
forces it's not going to be the
companies themselves so he says that
the external forces will be
the iron fist of government bureaucrats
and so this reveals to him what he calls
a suicidal impulse on the part of
business people then he has an
interesting set of reflections near the
end about what he calls political
principles he says the political
principle that underlies the market
mechanism is unanimity now when we talk
about something being unanimous it means
that everybody is on the same page
everybody agrees
and in a business transaction that has
to be the case if i want to make a
contract with you both of us have to
sign it if i make you sign it under
duress it's no good
so i have to appeal to you you have to
appeal to me we have to find some sort
of compromise that we're both good with
and then it's unanimous so he says in an
ideal free market resting on private
property no individual can coerce any
other all cooperation is voluntary all
parties to such cooperation benefit or
they need not participate there's no
there's no uh social responsibilities in
any other sense in the shared values and
responsibility of individuals that's
unanimity
then he says the political principle
that underlies the political mechanism
is conformity the individual must serve
a more general social interest whether
that be determined by a church or
dictator or majority the individual may
have a vote but then once they're
overruled they have to conform so if i
don't want the stadium to be built and i
protest outside and i don't want my
taxes to go to that but the majority
votes for the new stadium i'm paying the
taxes and that's all there is to it if
the majority of people love having a
military spread all over the world and
massive bloated defense expenditures
that dwarf even the top 15 rivals that
we have and most people seem to be cool
with it or at least our elected
representatives are
i'm stuck with it right that's that's
what he's calling conformity
and he's saying that
by talking about social responsibilities
business people are actually setting
themselves up to be moved from a
situation
governed by the principle of unanimity
to one that's governed by the principle
of conformity so he finishes by saying
that
here we go the doctrine of social
responsibility taken seriously would
extend the scope of the political
mechanism to every human activity it
would replace the market mechanism with
a political mechanism and
friedman is is sketching out something
rather widespread here he's only talking
primarily about businesses but we could
easily imagine this spreading to every
other domain of human existence
and so this is why he thinks that
there's a fundamental problem
with saying that businesses or
executives should be following social
responsibility and he argues the real
the real social responsibility is merely
to
increase its profits hence the title of
the essay
you